say that the challenges that we Face are
insurmountable and that we are
individually all collectively frolicking
toward an inescapable apocalypse I'm
absolutely not going to spend my final
moments with some buzzkill mood Hoover
telling me about how they knew that this
would happen all along that's not the
person I want to be around
Hello everybody welcome back to the show
it is a five-year anniversary episode
didn't plan on doing this but I thought
it might be nice to kind of recap some
of the lessons that have taken a little
bit longer to sink in some of the things
that have come about as a byproduct of
actually doing the show some of the
insights that I've gained from going
from somebody who was
29 and broadly lost and kind of didn't
really understand himself all that well
to now someone who is 34 and a tiny
little bit less lost and still doesn't
understand himself perfectly but does a
little bit better so I thought that this
might be an interesting insight into my
journey and some of the things that I've
really relied on over the last five
years
it goes without saying that I didn't
intend to be doing this in five years
time I just wanted to start a show and
see what would happen and I mean that's
one lesson to take away straight away
which is
you are going to struggle to predict the
outcomes that occur if you continue to
do something for a very very long period
of time it's really hard to work out
what that exponential curve of just
constant iteration Rogan calls it
building a mountain with layers of paint
and you just don't know how big that's
going to get and then you look back and
you go wow that's 600 episodes or a
thousand blog posts or however many tens
of thousands of hours it is playing the
violin or whatever you do but yes going
to get into some of my favorite lessons
from The Last Five Years on the show
who might as well get started
first one is a richer vocabulary means a
richer life this is a quote from Ludwig
Wittgenstein the limits of my language
mean the limits of my world this has
been something that I've relied on an
awful lot during the show because I
always loved vocabulary and language and
trying to be as colorful as possible and
precise as possible using the words that
I actually meant to to describe the
thing that I'm meaning to describe and
the limits of my language mean the
limits of My World Is A really lovely
description because
when you have an idea that's in your
brain up until the point at which it
forms itself into something a bit more
concrete which is usually language
unless you've created interpretive dance
or something it's going to be language
that you use to try and convey that not
only to other people which is important
but more importantly to yourself
up until the point at which you take an
idea in your head and form it into words
it remains a notion right it just it's
this ephemeral
difficult to Define sort of Cloudy
wishy-washy I can't grab a hold of it
type sense right you just use this this
sort of it's like a smell you have the
smell of an idea but when it's in word
form it's more concrete you can refine
it you can actually see it and break it
down
which means that if you have a broader
vocabulary if you have more words with
which you can describe the things that
are going on inside of your mind you can
actually describe them more effectively
and given the fact that it goes from
wishy-washy to concrete when you put
them into words it actually allows you
to experience a richer type of life
you can either keep everything in your
brain keep it in ephemeral notion smell
world and never have to Grapple with the
fact that your language is imprecise or
you can expand your vocabulary really
really get accurate with what you're
trying to describe and then you can play
around with ideas much more effectively
and this also ties in to something that
I've been a big fan of since starting
the show which is working on my speech
so it's not just about being able to put
the words down on paper I mean who when
was the last time that you wrote
half a page of anything unless you're a
doctor probably 10 years ago so speech
is going to be for the most part the
medium through which you convey these
ideas and this is another degree of
difficulty right because not only do you
now need to have the words in your
vocabulary you also need to have the
verbal agility to be able to get from
idea to brain to mouth
repurposed with the word that you need
out riding the crest of now it's an
unbelievably difficult thing to do and
then you form this
face shape that vibrates air that hits
somebody's ear that causes them to
understand what you mean I mean language
generally is just fascinating but the
point he remains that if you can expand
your capacity with regards to vocabulary
and with regards to speech in specifics
you're going to be
much more satisfied I think and I've
certainly felt a lot more satisfied as
that world has expanded as I've been
able to use more and more accurate and
precise language to describe the things
that are inside of my head
it's allowed me to see and experience
the things that I'm going through with
greater depth not just for communicating
it to other people
but also for myself so I guess the
lesson to take from that is to focus on
exposing yourself to new types of words
to not just
read something that's easy or always
contemporary or always pop cultury I've
got here uh The Melancholy death of
oyster Boy by Tim Burton which is poetry
and this is from my speech Coach and
he's been getting me to do poetry
because it's got these sort of weird
rhythms to it and um it's great uh I
learned the word bivalve the other day
which is I think kind of like a clam
yeah it must be because he's an oyster
obviously but just it's cool so expose
yourself to new words and it means that
you'll have a richer existence that's
the tldr
next one the tension between success and
a desire to feel like we're enough so
this is something
that I see in pretty much every
successful person that I'm friends with
um this includes myself but even people
that are you know further up the uh
mountain of success Than Me by a
distance
it's a problem that almost everybody
deals with so success is a strange thing
and the reason is presumably we want
success because we think that a more
successful life is going to bring us
more happiness and more meaning and more
fulfillment but the problem is that we
sacrifice the thing that we want which
is happiness for the thing which is
supposed to get it which is success
failure can make you miserable but I'm
not sure that success will make you
happy and one of the most common
dynamics that I've seen among High
performers is parents want their child
to do well so they encourage their child
to do well by praising them when they
succeed and criticizing them when they
fail but what that causes is the child
to learn that praise and admiration are
contingent on succeeding and that lesson
metastasizes through early adulthood
into I am only worthy of love and
acceptance and belonging if I succeed
and being powered by this internal
feeling of insufficiency that can drive
a human to do an awful lot of things you
can achieve a hell of a lot because
you're prepared to outwork and out
hustle and and out suffer everybody else
because they're not running just toward
a life that they want but you're also
running away from a life that you fear
and success and progress can ameliorate
these feelings of efficiency you're
constantly getting a new hit of dopamine
as you reach the next goal therefore
success and progress becomes prioritized
above everything else not only have you
been programmed in the past by parental
conditioning and previous success it is
also the anesthetic that kind of Bombs
Over the pain of insufficiency as well
and don't get me wrong like lots of high
performers do genuinely love
the work that they do that there are out
there I'm sure tons of people who are
driven by a well-balanced simple desire
to maximize their time on this planet
and not everybody that is a high
performer is trying to fill some
existential void inside of them but if I
was to place a bet I would guess that
the majority of high performers are
driven by a fear of insufficiency rather
than some perfectly balanced holistic
desire to be better and
I think on average that high Achievers
are more miserable than the normal
person
that was a question that I've asked a
bunch of different big name coaches
and they all seem to say the same thing
which is
yes high performance on average Michael
Gervais who was the guy that they
brought in to fix Felix Baumgartner the
dude that parachuted from the edge of
space he was struggling with
uh claustrophobia inside of this suit
which was going to go however many like
150 000 feet in the air
um he was struggling every time he got
in his heart rate was super high his
blood pressure was super high he just
wasn't able to perform and they brought
him in to fix it and he so he's worked
with a ton of NFL teams he's worked with
everybody right
the guide that fixed the man that jumped
from the edge of space's mentality said
most high performers are miserable so
what does it mean that the people who we
admire the most
are the ones who sometimes have the
least desirable internal States and also
if the pursuit of success is in an
effort to make us happy and in the
pursuit of success we make ourselves
miserable
why not just shortcut the entire process
and just be happy I I don't know if
that's even possible
because external accolades do count for
a lot and I also don't think that
getting rid of all of your worldly
possessions and retreating into a cave
in the woods is an optimal strategy I
think
some degree of external material success
is important because it makes us feel
validated and it satiates our desire for
status and respect but external success
isn't going to fill an internal void and
I came up with another Bro Science idea
of insufficiency adaptation which is if
your drive comes from a fear of
insufficiency and you continue to
disprove those fears with success in the
real world and yet those feelings of
insufficiency persist what makes you
think that the answer to this problem is
more success
if your drive comes from a fear of
insufficiency and you continue to
disprove those fears with success in the
real world yet the feeling of
insufficiency persists what makes you
think that the answer to this problem is
more success it's probably not right
it's probably something more deep-seated
it's going to be more difficult for you
to fix this problem than simply the next
trophy or the next award or the next
zero on your bank balance and I think
there is no clean answer here right the
world is messy and every human is
hopelessly irrational when compared with
what rationality actually looks like you
also don't need to let go of every
success goal but I do think spending
some time working out whether there is a
shorter more direct route to the life
that you want by removing obstacles
rather than pressing harder on the
accelerator
might be a good question to ask yourself
am I over complicating life is something
that I find myself asking quite a lot
like do I need all of these things to do
all of these things do I need all of
these possessions do I need to what is
it that genuinely brings me joy
what am I doing that doesn't contribute
toward that and which of these things
actually don't serve anything at all
maybe they're just patterns that I've
inculcated through habit or Paths of
least resistance or the way I've dealt
with trauma in the in the past or or
again this this uh sense of
insufficiency this void that needs
filling again like you might be
listening to this and go I don't get any
I all of My Success comes from this
perfectly balanced place I mean
fair play if that's you
um but I would
I would estimate that you were in the
minority and a very fortunate one so you
know count your blessings if that's true
and if you resonate with that story
which is this
sense of not being enough gets
solved it's it's it's fixed by the
uh a nice statistic uh solution uh that
comes with success and progress
um work out how much of the success over
complicates life and how much of it
actually contributes to your happiness
okay next one this is from James Clear
people get so caught up in the fact they
have limits that they rarely exert the
effort required to get close to them
people get so caught up in the fact they
have limits that they rarely exert the
effort required to get close to them
this
was tied in with something that I it
took me four years and 10 months to
actually realize and it was a
conversation with Michael malis toward
the back end of last year that really
put a name to it and you'll have had
this happen before where you've got this
idea or problem or concept that you're
really trying to wrestle with you need
to find a model for why it exists or
what it is and you're coming up with all
of these different ideas in your
searching and then after a while you
realize that it was a super obvious term
or words that existed and you were
already aware of and you just didn't
realize that that was the thing that you
were referring to All Along The again
the the limits of my language mean the
limits of my world and the word I was
looking for was cynicism right it's the
reason that I have a problem with
YouTube comments sometimes it's one of
the things that I rail against and
dislike most on the Internet it's one of
the biggest turn-offs in terms of
finding new friends for me uh it's one
of the reasons that I moved out to
America you know it is
so awful and destructive and boring
and it was cynicism and that was the
word that I was looking for all along
and this is why for the people that are
watching on YouTube I'm so grateful for
the audience that I've managed to build
because you guys are
for the most part not that cynical you
are very reasonable it's very insightful
take your time to watch and and listen
to the arguments that are being put
forward by someone even someone that you
might not like or don't agree with
before you actually spout out some
half-baked opinion and I mean this was
shown the Stephen Shore episode that was
whatever a couple of weeks ago
that had people opening up about
difficulties in becoming a mother or a
father or letting things go or it being
too late or fears for the Future these
are just random people on the internet
contributing on a platform which isn't
exactly known for its depth and nuance
and that made me feel very proud so for
those of you that are doing that uh
thank you and that also was what sparked
my insight around cynicism
uh with two comments on the episode with
malice and Malice is talking about a
reason to Hope right so
the Soviet Union uh the famines this
sort of brutality of their entire
process throughout all of the 1900s
basically
um would have been a good justification
that the bad guys are always going to
win that the world is not going to get
better that there is basically nothing
we can do
and yet they didn't win and yet it it
did end up being fixed it was a problem
that we could surmount and that is his
reason for hope his justification for
hope that coming back from the worst
that the world has ever had
to actually something that we wanted the
good guys one in his opinion and yeah
there was two comments on that that just
really nailed what I've been thinking
about cynicism so quote cynicism as
Michael espouses it is one thousand
percent a guarded response you're
setting yourself up against
disappointment the worst most obnoxious
black pilled cynics are pretty much
always heartbroken by their own
experiences and terrified to hope it's
more comfortable to get fatalistic and
call it pragmatism the cope is framing
hope as pathetic and embarrassing and
optimism as delusion which is projection
on their end it's sour grapes at an
existential level if everything sucks
and everyone is horrible and reality is
disappointing and you know that for a
fact it's the people acting like things
can be better that are dumb slash
delusional slash the problem and that's
so such a beautiful perfect dissection
of the exact tenor that I dislike on the
internet and those the second comment
which said
cynicism is a psychological protector
its role within the system is to protect
you against experiencing anything bad it
is a preemptive strike against a
perceived threat if I tell myself that
all women are bad then I'm less likely
to seek a relationship with women and as
a consequence I'm never going to feel
the pain of rejection if I tell myself
that everything is [__] or that things
will never get better then I'm excused
of ever having to try at anything the
upside of never trying is never having
to feel the pain of failure I mean
that's [__] that was better than
anything that me or malice said on the
episode so to those who comment us thank
you very much
um and it just it really
synthesized for me that this culture of
cynicism and pessimism is one of the
things that I'm most trying to rail
against I want a community and a
movement of people who see the good in
the world and who are agents of change
for themselves and for the people that
are around them they're people who take
control people who face down big
challenges with a grin on their face
because of the chance that they might
win right this is the energy that I want
for 2023 I don't want blind optimism but
I want blue sky self-belief and I back
myself and so should you I don't think
that
pessimism or cynicism is cool or fun to
be around and like okay let's even say
that I'm wrong right say that the
challenges that we Face are
insurmountable and that we are
individually or collectively frolicking
toward an inescapable apocalypse I'm
absolutely not going to spend my final
moments with some buzzkill mood Hoover
telling me about how they knew that this
would happen all along
that's not the person I want to be
around right
and this
agentic highly sovereign
Trend among people
is probably the single most common
factor between all of the friends that
I've accumulated all of the people that
I've resonated with all the people that
I've got on with the most and
it just seems to be that those are the
ones who win those are the ones who deal
with challenges the best so you can have
the the pessimism Viewpoint if you want
if that's the way that you want to go
about the world
but I don't think cynics are having that
much fun and I don't think that
insulating yourself from failure by
guaranteeing it individually is
particularly cool uh and again even if
it is the case that everything's going
to hell in a handbasket like
I don't want to be with you man like I
don't want to spend my time with you so
that was a big a really really big
Insight that kind of
like optimism really is is something
that I've been aiming toward for a long
time and yeah it took me four years and
10 months to reverse engineer the word
hope
into into a podcast anyway next one
the vestigial pattern bias
the successful deliberate approaches we
learned during our development can
become a prison which stops us from
becoming more free-flowing and at ease
when we are developed the tools that got
you from naught to 50 are not the same
ones that will get you from 50 to 90 or
90 to 95 but we found success with this
approach in the past so we cling on to
an overly rational deliberate approach
we hope that applying pure cerebral
horsepower to a situation will fix it
without realizing that our subconscious
has aggregated the thousands of hours of
experience that we've clocked up now and
not using that experience is keeping us
in the same league that we've always
been in so this is something that I see
very heavily in business and I've also
seen it in kind of any practical Pursuit
where you have a lot of direct control
over what's going to go on so if you're
a business owner or if you're somebody
who is growing a platform
anybody that's trying to do a physical
Pursuit
there will be a
series of sort of very deliberate steps
that you go through uh you may be
overbearing some would say or you may
struggle to relinquish control within a
business let's say right you've always
done this in the past this is the way
that things have always been done and
you'd very much struggle to pass this on
to somebody else you delegate down you
can't bear to see somebody else do it
because they're going to do it slightly
wrong what you don't realize is that
that was great when your business was
first starting out but it's absolutely
terrible when you're trying to scale it
and the same thing goes for let's say
that you do a podcast and let's say that
you struggle to relinquish control over
adreads or the audio edits or whatever
it might be
you are going to cap how much work you
can do because you're bouncing off the
limit of the number of hours in a day
and also you struggle to
be more free-flowing and encapsulate
um all of the experience that you've got
and be able to use that rather than
having to be so deliberate you know if
you've done something a thousand times
you can afford to actually be a bit more
creative and maybe after you've learned
the rules perhaps even break some of the
rules but until you know the rules it's
very difficult to break them that's not
breaking them that's just not
understanding how to play the game so
Ian mcgilchrist guy that wrote The
Master in his Emissary fantastic
really great insight
um had a conversation with him and it
was an interesting time last year
because I was really really digging into
this tension between cognition and
intuition right this sort of
battle between the two uh and letting go
of thinking and relying on feeling to
make decisions and guide your actions
and this is very much his domain and it
relates to what we were talking about
before because when you first start out
doing anything you have very little
useful experience to rely on so instead
many people a lot of the sort of people
that will listen to a podcast like this
one will rely on just straight up
cerebral horsepower they you'll out
think and out obsess and outwork the
competition in order to become more
effective and this cognitive deliberate
strategy will work great because it's an
area of Effectiveness that only a small
number of people can get to it's very
effortful
but it is very effective and the
interesting challenge
is what happens a few years later when
you've accumulated some experience
because now is the time when you can
stop being so deliberate and you can
start being more effortless and natural
and graceful with how you conduct your
pursuit of choice an example of this was
uh Ian mcgilchrist looked at the
motorbike races on the Isle of Man uh
time trial and they discovered so this
this time trial for the people that
don't know the Isle of man's a tiny
little island
um off the coast of Britain
they race on
streets not like Miami streets they race
on country roads B roads with sheer
Cliffs and dry stone walls and potholes
and right-hand turns this is not
purpose-built this isn't purpose built
to be a normal Road this is like bad
roads to just drive down let alone to
race down at 200 miles an hour and Ian
looked at these races and realized that
they're operating at a speed where their
conscious processing doesn't have time
to kick in so the a big chunk of the
race is done exclusively on Instinct
they're not thinking shift down turn
left a little bit of break get back on
the power
they are they are doing all of this just
like back of the brain and the the goal
is actually to switch off the front of
the brain and there's an ease and speed
and wisdom available from our gut which
gets shut down when we rely on this more
cognitive rational approach for
everything that we do this is also what
I learned from Edward slingle and the
guy that wrote Drunk
he's saying that switching off your uh
PFC your prefrontal cortex is actually
one of the best things that you can do
for creativity because as soon as you
try to focus really really hard there
are certain areas of the brain that are
great for creativity that get shut off
so there is this
interesting challenge that you may be
facing and I know that I do very
regularly which is the period after
you've accumulated experience but before
you've learned to rely on your gut and
this is something that I've memed as the
chasm of cognitive effort so you've
ingrained a habit of conscious control
for years and years and this habit has
been rewarded with success reinforcing
it and making it seem like a very
effective strategy but just like when
Tiger Woods had to configure his entire
golf swing from scratch to go from being
one of the best in the world to the very
best sometimes there is a ceiling to
your current approach what got you here
won't get you there and Confucius talks
about this really interesting kind of
reprogramming when realizing Wu way
which is natural action it's sort of
thinking without thinking quote in the
early stages of training an aspiring
Confucian gentleman needs to memorize
entire shelves of archaic texts learn
the precise angle at which to Bow and
learn the lengths of the steps with
which he is to enter a room his sitting
mat must always be perfectly straight
all of this rigor and restraint however
is ultimately aimed at producing a
cultivated but nonetheless genuine form
of spontaneity indeed the process of
training is not considered complete
until the individual has passed
completely beyond the Need For Thought
or effort so the next stage of your
development might not be more effort but
more ease might be less grind and more
grace and this Chasm of cognitive effort
is something that
certainly a lot of my friends and myself
get stuck in right that you can
really struggle
to let go of a strategy
which gave you success in the past I
know
if I'm faced with a challenge that if I
apply tons of cerebral horsepower to it
it'll go away
problem is
that doesn't scale you can't do that for
everything for the rest of time I mean
you can you could do that but it's going
to restrict how far you can get because
it's not very scalable it's not very
leverageable it's very effortful it's
going to tie you out it isn't easily
delegated
you know all of this
ties together into letting go just
finding a little bit more ease and that
Chasm of cognitive effort and clambering
back out of it
um one increasingly more easy uh
handheld at a time is something that I
think is quite important
next one I watched a great video where
uh Charlie Munger was it'll be one of
those end of year uh report things it
gives an AGM him and Warren Buffett give
these talks and he's always sat on stage
with a can of Coke and he said that what
drives the world isn't greed it's envy
and the quote was our lives are
objectively the best Humanity has ever
had yet complaining and dissatisfaction
are high as ever
humans don't want their lives to just be
better they want them to be better than
their neighbors and their parents and
the people they see on social media in
this way a highly connected life is
influencing your expectations and envy
through comparison so
you can imagine that you would track
your status in a local tribe and in a
small hierarchy like that it was super
important ancestrally because
you need to know where you sit and the
problem is that we haven't learned how
to knock that switch off even though we
are comparing ourselves essentially with
seven billion other people on the
internet and if the Theodore Roosevelt
quote which is comparison is the thief
of Joy was right in a world where we can
compare more
it'll commensurately be one with less
happiness right if you have more
comparison which will drive more Envy
not greed more Envy you're trying to
play keeping up with the Joneses you're
using this ancient programming to try
and
check where you are in the status
hierarchy
and you're now competing with an entire
Globe an entire civilization of humans
perhaps understandably your feelings of
insufficiency are going to continue to
arise especially if you're one of these
people who was taught when you were a
kid that
praise is really only worthy of present
uh feeling of belonging and feeling like
you're enough is contingent on what it
is that you do and achieve
this can all kind of congeal into a
pretty negative worldview
um or one at the very least which is a
very externalized it's not about you
it's not about what you can do it's
about what you do compared with
everybody else it's not about your
Pursuits it's about how good your
Pursuits are compared with everyone else
I always think about this there's an
interesting story to do with the Mr
Olympia
competition so
one of the challenges that you have if
you want to become Mr Olympia is
you need to beat the second place guy or
you need to beat the next best guy in
order to be able to come first so if you
miss time it and you are in the same era
as Dorian Yates or Arnold Schwarzenegger
or Ronnie Coleman or Jay Cutler these
Legends of the sport
you can still be unbelievably good you
can be world class you can be better
than world class you could be the best
in the world ever
minus one you could be the second best
in the world that's ever been in this
Sport and if you time it wrong you're
always going to be second and this is
the problem of using any external metric
of success to gauge your own self-worth
that you aren't inevitably Outsourcing
your own sense of self-worth you're
crowdsourcing it to the world around you
and that's going to lead to problems you
are going to encounter a world which is
pretty indifferent doesn't really care
about what you want that could be very
poorly timed for what you're trying to
achieve and you will suffer
next one
do you want to be known for your work or
your takes so this is from Andrew
huberman and this was something I've
been thinking about for ages and again
it took somebody else's language to um
put this into words for me so quote
advice I got early in my career don't
over engage in any controversy unless
you are willing to stake your entire
reputation on it rather keep focused on
discovering new things and creating or
else you will become known for the
controversy and nothing else there is no
going back that's huberman so this
desire for drama this compulsion that
people have this gravitational pull that
they have to inject themselves into
culture War topics or whatever it might
be is alluring right and don't get me
wrong like I'll I'll talk about
grammarly and chat GPT using like
Progressive words because it's funny
there is a degree of game playing that
everybody does and I'm by no means
immune from that however
there are some people for whom that is
their life they you can tell it's what
gets them they they have been subsumed
by the drama
so much so that it has completely taken
over their personality there is no one
home apart from them being a vehicle for
the culture War
that is not the person that I want to be
I don't want to be known for the drama I
want to be known for my ideas and the
work that I do and the people I talk
with and the conversations that I have
and sometimes those two will cross over
right like that's totally fine
but you can imagine the world in which
someone just basically becomes a puppet
for whatever they're like a cook for
drama right they're simping for drama if
there's any opportunity to interject
themselves into a remotely cantankerous
conversation online they'll do it
because they see it as an opportunity to
gain some easy clout because people are
naturally drawn to drama even where
there isn't Ernie and that's the people
that created out of nowhere not only I
mean is it it makes the internet a worse
place to be and these are the precisely
the sorts of people that I mute even the
ones that are very big and well known
but also it makes me feel Beyond
annoying being annoying it makes me feel
pity for them I really really feel bad
for what their normal home life must be
like what's it like being married to
someone that exists like this it's
something I don't want and then I
realized that one of the reasons that
I'd been holding back a little bit in
terms of
that whole kind of very bombastic out
there flashy communication which for a
long time right is a club promoter
coming up for anybody that remembers uh
my uh Facebook from back in the day it
was
flagrant call outs of people that were
competitor promoters about
like some guys Hostess that one of the
lads that worked for us had got with
last week but they worked for a
different company it was
um your comments about their club night
comments about their cut like anything
that I could find right that I thought
would rile somebody else up
so going from that world to this one
might not feel like oh wow you
discovered that not being a dick on the
Internet is a game-changing way to
retain some sanity like okay yeah
perhaps that's not amazing news for
everybody but for me and for a lot of
people I think that have been in a world
where they did exist in the Cesspool of
causing drama on the internet uh it is
quite a big realization and another
thing that I realized is that if you
want to get people on side with whatever
argument or movement it is that you
believe
if you really really understand human
nature you don't want to trigger a
tribal response like if you genuinely
understand the way that human behavior
works if you make somebody feel silly or
you ridicule them they will dig their
heels in so much more tightly and
they're not coming over to your side
even they're going to be more Brazen
they they're going to be reinforced in
their beliefs even more right so
I learned that triggering a tribal
response is antithetical to having an
effective behavior and belief changing
message it's nowhere near as sexy for me
or for the guests that I speak to to
heavily caveat right there it seems to
be the case that in my best estimation
it seems it may be based on the evidence
and the research that like it's nowhere
near as sexy to do that than to just
come storming out of the gates and make
some black and white accusation about
the way that the world is and this is
the same when you're having a
conversation at work whether you're
trying to have a negotiation with your
partner it is nowhere near as cool to do
that now
when you're talking on the internet you
want to try about some people like the
idea of coming across as this like
flaming Warrior of of truth that's just
slicing through things with this sort of
insight but for the most part almost all
situations are messy and chaotic and it
very rarely is as cut and dry so it
isn't as sexy to caveat heavily which
the guests do and which I I do a lot as
well but when it comes to really
important subjects the most compelling
arguments I think are the gentle ones
they're the ones where if I'm going to
try and convince somebody or if you need
to try and convince somebody
that maybe population collapse is a
topic that they should take seriously
that maybe
um men falling behind in education and
employment is of concern not only to men
but also to women and to society and to
the civilization at large perhaps these
are important topics if you steam in and
start accusing girls of being
hypergamous thoughts and [__] and
idiots and like you don't care about men
what do you think the outcome of that is
going to be do you think that that's
going to be effective behavioral change
do you think that that's going to
convince people who already disagree
with your point of view
or might taking them through things one
step at a time be better now maybe this
is just the stage that I'm at maybe in
five years time if I eat a bit more
liver and my testosterone doubles I'm
just gonna be a flagrant like flaming
Warrior the same as everybody else but
um at the moment I prefer this approach
I think that it definitely seems to be
more effective at convincing people of
Novel new
um insights and and changing their
opinions
and also stepping through things very
very gently like this
seems to have worked well for a lot of
the people that I respect
most of the people who I think have a
really great approach to that public
online Persona that one that I like and
one that if you were working in an
office if you're trying to manage a home
if you're trying to be a part of a
sports team
I could see as not only being more
effective but protecting your sanity
like you want you are going to bring on
yourself way more uh psychological
distress by making yourself a lightning
rod for the politics in your sports team
or the politics in your kids school or
the Rouse in your argument or the
disagreements in your office
just stepping through things that
doesn't mean backing down that just
means not steaming in with
like insults and and backhanded passive
aggressive comments and stuff that's not
the way to go so anyway that's where I'm
at at the moment give me
five years and I might be exactly I
might have to send it into the muck in
the Maya the same as everybody else but
for now that's where I'm at okay next
one
so this is
a really really great Insight from Alex
homozy he says
when I'm 50 I trade everything I own to
be 33 my current age again which means
right now is more important than all the
wealth I'll ever accumulate you'd give
it all to live again today
all of the money that he makes he's
already worth 100 million or something
all of the money that he makes between
now and 17 years time he would trade all
of that in 17 years time
to be his age right now
which means all of the money that he
makes is less important
than
the the experiences that he has in front
of him
that's a pretty heavy realization right
and related to what we were talking
about earlier on that happiness and
success trade we trade the thing that we
want which is time for the thing which
is supposed to get it which is money we
give up time to make money so that we
can finally have more time when we have
enough money we give up happiness to
achieve success so that we can have more
happiness when we achieve enough success
this yet again comes back to the is
there a quicker route to the life that I
want to have am I making money because I
think that making money is the thing
that I need to do in order to make
myself happy but when I actually assess
the standard of living that I need to be
at what I realize is that I'm already
there or I'm not going to be far off
within the space of the next five years
so actually driving myself into the
ground or having all of these different
side hustles which don't fire me up
maybe I don't need to do that now if
they are things that genuinely fire you
up fantastic lean into them as much as
you want and if they on the byproduct
earn you a ton of money then even better
it is very difficult for you to separate
out and distill apart how much of this
is something that you want to do and how
much of this is something which is a
byproduct of social norms and the
influence of of society at large right
you everybody else values tons and tons
of money why shouldn't you I mean you
know the the classic hustle and grind
mentality of it's great to earn a
million dollars because it's way easier
to turn one into ten than it is to turn
100 Grand into 10.
really is that is is so just endless
never stopping monetary growth is your
primary goal in life
I don't know I mean for me that's not
the way that I see things I'm fortunate
that I didn't come from money which
means that
Everything feels like a bonus any
anything over a graduate job feels like
an insane amount of money so and I also
understand that people come from
different backgrounds there are people
who grow up either in wealth or in
families that felt like
they treated gifts as their primary mode
of showing love and again if that's you
you have the opportunity to deprogram
that in part I don't know how heritable
materialism is but there will be some
movement that you have you have some
control over reprogramming this and your
life will be way way better if you stop
judging yourself based on the number of
zeros in your bank account and it means
you can actually choose to do the thing
that you want to do more effectively
because you're not beholden to
sacrificing happiness for money or
sacrificing time for money time is the
thing that we want money is the thing
that's supposed to get it by finally
giving us enough money to have time and
we sacrifice that time in order to
achieve it it's so circular anyway
there's a concept called nexting which I
was recently introduced to and it is a
single word descriptor of one of my
favorite speeches from Sam Harris ever
so I'm going to read that to you now
quote as a matter of conscious
experience the reality of your life is
always now and I think that this is a
liberating truth about the nature of the
human mind in fact I think there's
probably nothing more important to
understand about your mind than that if
you want to be happy in this world
the past is a memory it is a thought
arising in the present the future is
merely anticipated it is another thought
arising now what we truly have is this
moment
and this
and we spend most of our Lives
forgetting this truth refuting it
fleeing it overlooking it and the horror
is that we succeed we manage to never
really connect with the present moment
and find fulfillment there because we
are continually hoping to become happy
in the future
and the future never arrives it is
always now
however much you feel you need to plan
for the future to anticipate it to
mitigate risks the reality of your life
is now
even when we think we're in the present
moment we're in very subtle ways always
looking over its shoulder anticipating
what's coming next we're always solving
a problem
and it's possible to Simply drop your
problem if only for a minute and enjoy
whatever is true of your life in the
present
maybe all of the things are at the very
least many of the things that we do are
an attempt to give ourselves a good
enough reason to just be here existing
in the present moment so being choked
during sex stops the chatter of our mind
as does drugs as does alcohol and
fighting and reading and dancing on a
beach as a DJ plays a set
the goal as awakened humans should be to
lower the height of the bar of stimulus
that you need so that you can be present
without having any of these inputs right
you shouldn't need to have a
perfect
psychopharmacological cocktail of drugs
and best friends and nature and sound
and everything in order for you to just
have an excuse to be here in the present
moment does it help
for you to not be in a complete
nightmare scenario with a ton of worries
and a concern straight around the corner
yes it does
would it be easier to be super present
if you're on top of Everest yes it would
but in between those two situations you
need to try and find a way to just be
present and enjoy the moment right now
you're not going to live Peak
experiences every single day and there's
a quote from Naval which I love which is
if you can't be present with a coffee
you won't be present with a yacht
a bastardized it a little bit it's if uh
you can't be happy with the coffee you
won't be happy with the yacht but if you
can't be present with a coffee you won't
be present on a yacht right
what gives you the impression that your
problems will be fixed by more money
right if more success continues to come
along the Imposter adaptation thing if
more success continues to come along and
doesn't fix your problems of feeling
like an imposter it's got nothing to do
with more success the same thing goes
for if you can't be present in the
moment no matter what it is that you're
doing what makes you think that a bigger
house or more money or more followers
online is going to be that answer and
you can think about how many times your
presence has been hijacked by fears or
worries or hopes for the future or
problems or regrets or victories around
problems of the past as you flee from
boredom before it even rears its head
with the screen in your pocket you are
so averse to time without distraction
that all of us have become addicted to
solving problems
so much so that we create problems
purely for the purpose of solving them
but what we truly have
is this moment
letting go of that desire that
requirement to always be in motion to
always be in conflict
is very very difficult but it's
something that I am
um
trying quite hard to do
okay next one
uh are we here oh this is brilliant so
a little bit of evolutionary psychology
and I've always been thinking about this
this one quote that I've brought up a
ton of times on the show that you're
probably familiar with to do with
happiness and becoming aware
there is a
relationship between why you do things
now
now in the moment and what their purpose
is long term evolutionarily and I only
learned about this a couple of weeks ago
and it's called proximate and ultimate
reasons for human behavior so Dr Tanya
Reynolds came on the show and she said
that natural selection favors certain
behaviors but doesn't necessarily favor
us having explicit awareness of why we
do what we do natural selection favors
certain behaviors but doesn't
necessarily favor us having explicit
awareness of why we do what we do so in
order to properly understand human
behavior we have to understand both the
ultimate and the proximate explanations
so ultimate explanations are concerned
with why a behavior exists and proximate
explanations are concerned with how it
works so uh Proxima would be the more
immediate reason to do a behavior so sex
feels good and gives you pleasure and
love ultimate would be the reason why
the behavior was shaped that way by
Evolution so it creates Offspring who
continue you your genetic line right
immediate and long term
the behavior here is the same right it's
still just sex the explanations for it
though are based on different sets of
factors that incorporate physiological
versus evolutionary motivations and the
reason that this is interesting is
because some of the responses that I'd
seen to conversations around
evolutionary psychology so
I told Schultz that a non-negligible
contributor to the reason that the body
positivity movement gets so much intense
support from skinny women is because it
reduces these skinny women's mating
competition from bigger women by bmiing
them out of the dating pool which means
less competition for potential partners
and some women perhaps unsurprisingly
took issue
with my explanation and I can see why
because it's a pretty ungracious
characterization of their support of the
body positivity movement it's saying
like no guy you're reading way too much
into it this isn't what I think about at
all I just want to support my friends
like look
the proximate and ultimate explanations
aren't at odds with each other they
actually support each other indeed they
live very much in harmony they're just
at different levels of perspective and
abstraction so other examples might be
why we like fats and sugars in our food
the proximate would be that it tastes
good the ultimate would be that it
provides ancestrally rare energy rich in
high calories and sustenance which
should improve our chances of survival
why would we like symmetrical faces in
our partners the proximate would be they
look attractive the ultimate would be
symmetrical faces are genetically harder
to create and they indicate better
quality of genes which would be passed
on for our future potential Offspring
The Reason two and the reason for these
actions aren't counter to each other
right so revisiting that quote from
Tanya natural selection favors certain
behaviors but doesn't necessarily favor
us having explicit awareness of why we
do what we do one problem here
with having the veil of ultimate
explanation ignorance lifted from our
eyes is that makes us feel a lot less
agentic it's less in control of our own
desires when more cynical and contrived
and manipulative that's how it can make
us feel and
you know someone might say I don't mind
preferring partners with symmetrical
faces but as soon as I realized that
this preference is essentially my
desires being puppeted like Evolutions
marionette it feels less virtuous and
self-chosen right it's the same reason
why
um the women who
I uh suggested maybe supporting the body
positivity movement for more than just
the reason of wanting their friends to
feel okay
now have to face down the less noble
idea that maybe they're not perfectly
altruistic
friend supporters maybe there are some
uh rather awkward motivations going on
inside and you go well look I
you don't get to control those parts of
you in the same way as you railing you
somehow being uh an immoral person
because you have small feet or because
you have blue eyes or something like
it's just these are the precepts that
are inside of us
so the answer to this discomfort which I
think a lot of people feel and I
apologize for all of the conversations
about evolutionary psychology which does
reveal this veil of ultimate uh Behavior
explanation
think the best answer that I've found so
far is to find play like you have to
laugh at the absurdity of being a
sovereign creature who feels like they
have their own will but is driven by
Millennia old preferences to help you
survive and reproduce like you just you
have to find a way to make this funny or
else you're going to cry yourself to
sleep and that quote that I absolutely
adore ultimately happiness comes down to
choosing between the discomfort of
becoming aware of your mental
afflictions or the discomfort of
becoming ruled by them
you have the choice I mean people you
will have friends who
perfectly just
Waltz through life they don't really end
up challenging themselves with concerns
of whether they're self-actualizing or
anything else
are they
are they living a happier life
very well they may be
but as with Pandora's box or squeezing
toothpaste out of a tube once it is out
it is not going back in and if you're
the sort of person that I imagine
listens to this kind of content for an
hour already you are the kind of person
for whom it is going to be very
difficult to unsee things that you've
seen so as soon as you realize that your
reasons for your behavior might not be
quite as Noble as you thought you need
to learn more in order to be able to
transcend and include that right the
only alternative is to exist in this
sort of awful Middle Ground where you
know that you're Maybe
your uh Noble behaviors aren't quite as
Noble as you thought
and just allow yourself to to what
ignore them to to kind of exist with
this Paradox going on you're not going
to close the loop on okay what does this
mean how do I how do I include the fact
that I have both
ancient programming and sort of modern
day sovereignty blended with each other
how do I how do I make this work
together and the best solution that I've
found
to just laugh about it to just find it
funny that you are a rider on top of an
elephant right and you can pretend that
you're driving the car and or driving
the elephant and getting it to go where
you want but for the most part you're at
the mercy of the elephant so okay like
allow the elephant to go learn how to
have a good relationship with your
elephant
and just laugh about it
okay next one so this is a passage from
turning pro and this was pretty
formative given that this episode was
inspired by doing five years of this
podcast uh turning pro was a turning
point for me I
read it three years ago at the start of
the pandemic
and
I actually read sorry I read the war of
art which is Stephen pressfield book and
then turning pro is a chapter in the war
of art which he then turned into a
sequel and they're both great and you
can get both of them by going to
chriswillx.com books that is a list of
100 books you should read before you die
and it'll explain why I like them in a
little bit more detail and there's links
to go and get them and there's also 98
of the books that you can crack on with
um
the court says the amateur is a
narcissist he views the world
hierarchically he continually writes
himself in relation to others becoming
self-inflicted if his fortunes rise and
desperately anxious if his star should
fall the amateur sees himself as the
hero not only of his own movie but in
the movies of others he insists in his
mind if nowhere else that others share
this View
that
self-inflated of his fortunes rise and
desperately anxious if his star should
fall is exactly what I was saying before
to do with the externalizing of your
self-worth to whatever the market or the
follow account or the
other competitors on the Mr Olympia
stage or the girls at the bar or the
people at work say or behave or judge
you as right
you have to find somewhere more firm to
stand than exclusively Outsourcing your
own sense of self-worth
to the whole world around you it is
going to end up with you being ragged
around at the mercy of the market
and other people's heads are a wretched
place for your self-worth to live I can
promise you this as somebody who found
an awful lot of pleasure and took an
awful lot of pride in desperately wanted
to be liked by people that
there is no amount
of
other people's praise which is going to
fill that void like it has to come from
within it straight up has to come from
within now it can be supported and
buttressed by people and good friends
and all the rest of it
but it's you it's it's you first and
foremost it's you
um and like I say I read that I read
that book three years ago and that that
was when we went from two episodes a
week to three week and I really decided
okay I'm gonna try
my best this podcast thing and really
try and commit myself and I go to speech
coach and I got a
um me and Dean settled into a much more
rigorous routine with how we would get
things done and I learned YouTube and I
all of these are the bits and pieces but
it was a commitment and
um that's why I'm always going to have a
big affinity for the ideas in turning
pro and
um yeah that
externalizing of the inflating and
anxious cycle really hit me like you do
not want to Outsource your sense of
self-worth to the people around you you
cannot allow yourself to be buffeted
around at the mercy of things that
aren't under your control you are built
to achieve whatever it is that you're
trying to achieve you're more resilient
you're more attentive you're more
mindful you are enough to do whatever
the thing is that you're trying to do
you do not need
certification from The World At Large
that you are enough you already are
and that is something that took so so
long for me to to get to grips with and
I mean that
uh homozy quote which
I someone got a hold of and made into a
video and went just bananas on the
internet which is funny because it was
me quoting someone else to someone else
uh and that was the thing it wasn't
anything I'd come up with uh but homozy
who says uh you do not build
self-confidence by shouting affirmations
in the mirror you build it by having a
stack of undeniable proof that you are
who you say you are outwork yourself
doubt
that is how you learn that you are
worthy like just continue to do things
that make you proud of yourself
Integrity building
Pride inducing good honorable virtuous
Behavior keeping promises to yourself
getting up on time when you said that
you would do doing hard things when you
should having difficult conversations
when you should telling the truth even
when it's difficult those are the things
that are going to make you feel very
proud of yourself
okay where are we at our um give me
about an hour
let's do
two more okay so uh the talk Ville
Paradox this is from gwynda Bogle uh
friend slash one of the big Fanboy uh
moments I've this is another thing right
by the way as
um whatever you want to say like thought
leaders or interesting people on the
internet become democratized and there's
more and more of them you will have the
opportunity to become friends with
someone who you are both genuinely
actually friends with and also a massive
Fanboy over their work and this is a
strange uh middle ground that I don't
think used to exist so previously the
people that
um created things that were well known
and worthy of renown would be out of the
reach of almost everybody and the small
group of people that they were friends
with
um would
it would be a problem that only a few
people would encounter whereas now
someone like guinda right who is just a
a really phenomenal writer great sub
stacker but just a normal bloke right
like he's not he's not a Jordan Peterson
or anything like that
uh and we speak pretty regularly and yet
I obsessively read every single thing
that he writes so it's kind of like it's
kind of like being
being your mate's biggest fan at the
same time it's just a bizarre world I
don't know if that even makes sense but
it's just it's an odd World anyway uh
this is something that he taught me
about called the talkville paradox
as the living standards in a society
rise people's expectations of the
society rise with it the rise in
expectations eventually surpasses the
rise in living standards inevitably
resulting in disaffection and sometimes
populist uprisings so you can imagine
that
um concept creep which is as a problem
becomes ever rarer you need to expand
the definition in order to be able to
keep the problem the same level so
racism let's say by pretty much any
quantifiable metric racism appears to
have declined over the last 100 years
and yet if you were to listen to certain
media Outlets they would suggest that
racism is as bad as it's ever been or
maybe even worse it wouldn't be
surprising if
headlines from certain news articles
would say something like uh it's 1816
all over again I don't know what year it
is whatever the whatever the bad year is
that they don't like 1764 whatever the
whatever that year was that they don't
like
foreign
they concept creeped that out
which relates to the talk field Paradox
as the living standards rise people's
expectations rise with it so you can see
when you blend these two concepts
together that what you end up with is
natural a natural sense of disaffection
hang on the world was supposed to be
getting better but it's not getting
better as well as I wanted it to I now
feel aggrieved and out of place and I'm
upset why hasn't this happened this
encourages a victimhood mentality you
can see exactly how this would create
that Downstream from it living standards
arising expectations rise expectations
continue to rise because imagination is
Unbound and sadly you know GDP and the
amount of space that we have to give you
a nice New Living Room isn't
therefore you're going to find a problem
you're going to find a problem with your
education with your employment with your
place of society with your status with
your partner with everything that it is
that's going to cause you to feel
disaffected that's going to cause you to
feel cynical relating back to what we
said earlier on you know the world
cannot give me what I want therefore
there must be a problem with the world
and not with me therefore nothing is
ever going to go well as opposed to
sometimes things just do go well and I
don't get to see them I have a
negativity bias because it's easier for
us and more important for us as humans
to identify the things that go wrong
rather than things that go right
and yeah that is a good prophylactic to
wear I think when you can't understand
why people are getting so
vociferous online so
so
um detached from
your experience of the world or what you
think their experience of the world
should be ie1 which is positive this is
a very nice protection strategy go okay
right
Paradox suggests that people's
expectations can outstrip the reality's
ability to deliver it to them and
concept creep means that they're going
to find problems where there aren't any
because that is the way that they can
continue to complain and Achieve
victimhood within a certain
categories
it makes you feel a little bit less
insane or at least it did for me so I
hope it helps uh last one right
you cannot underestimate how normal the
normies are the reason that I put this
in is
a lot of my friends and a lot of you
guys as well I would guess
ah going to see yourself and compare
yourself up against the absolute Killers
within whatever
cohort you like whatever Pursuit it is
that you are trying to achieve and do
well in so if you are big into
discipline and motivation season right
you're going to compare yourself to
Jocko and Goggins if you're big into
um speech and uh recall and intellectual
ideas you're going to compare yourself
to Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson if
you're big into debating you're going to
compare yourself with Alex O'Connor and
and Ben Shapiro
your ability to understand how far you
are from almost every normal person is
completely skewed by only ever looking
up at who stood on the top of the
mountain that you're trying to climb at
the moment
just by being the sort of person that
listens to podcasts right just by that
forget what it is that you listen to you
can listen to the like the most inane
pointless podcast in the world just by
doing that just by having a desire for
slightly slower
than Tick Tock velocity content
consumption you're already separating
yourself out from the pack I think if I
was to make a guess if you were the sort
of person that goes to the gym three
times a week you're probably in the 0.
not one percent
of Fitness enthusiasts on the planet
maybe more maybe even more so than that
like that is how
ridiculously and this is if you go in
and you half asset right you go in and
you just sort of float around you do a
few sets you get a bit of a sweat on and
you're out within 45 minutes if you do
that three times a week you're up in
such a rarified elite strategy a a
strata of people
I think it's important for you and me
and everybody within this world to
remember just how
rare
and
odd it is to spend this much time being
curious about yourself and about the
world
the fact that you decide to work on
yourself the fact that you hold yourself
to high standards and you care about
things like telling the truth or finding
agency or or filling your potential or
paying it forward
these are really really really difficult
sometimes evolutionarily uh
disadvantageous
effortful challenging
tough things to do
and you are deciding to do them and
that's [__] cool right that is
something that everybody should be proud
about and the difference between the
center of the normal distribution and
where you are is absolutely [__]
massive and you cannot understand just
how far away from that you are even even
on your worst days you are still so much
further ahead and I think realizing that
living in that growth abundance
mentality is a
a good way to continue to give yourself
a sense of
hope
and reassurance and confidence that
you're moving in the right direction
anyway I'm gonna leave it there
I love you all five years nearly 600
episodes uh
insane thank you very much thank you for
making it to the end Chris willx.com
books if you want to get 100
life-changing books that you should read
before you die it's got some reason
about why I like them and links to go
and buy them and that's it I'll see you
at 10. what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]